-Our first guest tonight is
a talented actress who you know
from the movies "Lady Bird"
and "Booksmart."
She plays Monica Lewinsky
in the limited series
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story,"
which airs Tuesdays, only on FX.
Let's take a look.
-I don't understand why
you have this
and I don't understand
what is happening.
Why is this happen...
Linda, what did you do?!
-Please welcome back to
the show our friend
Beanie Feldstein, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you for having me.
-It's so great to have you here.
-Oh, my God!
-It's so nice.
They're so happy to see you.
-Me too.
-And we're -- I'm not just happy
that you're here at the show.
It's also very nice to have you
back in New York City.
I know this is home.
I know you were away for a long
time working on "Impeachment."
Are you happy to be back?
-I'm back in the
New York groove, baby.
I'm here.
I'm so happy to be back.
I just smile, but no one
can see it under my mask.
When I walk around, I'm just
like, "I'm so happy to be here."
-Your eyes. There's a light in
your eyes when you smile.
-There's, like, a real smizing
happening in my eyes, for sure.
-And we've talked in the past.
Obviously, this is not a secret
that you are a great fan of
musical theater.
Have you been able go back
and see shows yet?
Have done it?
-Yes.
My partner, Bon,
had never seen "Hamilton."
So, I was like, "I have to take
you to see 'Hamilton.'"
And she's British,
so she loved the king.
I was like, "That's not
the takeaway of 'Hamilton.'"
She was like, "Oh, yay!"
But we had the greatest time.
We saw Freestyle Love Supreme.
We saw "Nollywood Dreams"
at MCC.
It's been so great to be back
at the theater.
-That's really exciting.
And we were talking backstage
about "Funny Girl."
I mean, this is a show
that has never been revived.
An iconic part played by
Barbra Streisand.
-It's Barbra Streisand.
-It's Barbra Streisand, but --
-It's just Barbra Streisand.
-You know, so you must have --
I mean, I don't know if
hesitation's the right word,
but, like, what's it like
to take on something like that?
-It's insane.
I mean, it's truly
the first dream I ever had.
"Funny Girl" was my
obsession as a 2-year-old.
Normal.
Like, I begged my mom to make my
third birthday party
"Funny Girl"-themed.
So, you know, like,
at Party City, you have, like,
Elmo plates and
"Beauty and the Beast."
And I was like, "Where is the
Fanny Brice balloons?"
And she was like,
"They don't exist."
It didn't click for me.
But I literally had
a "Funny Girl"-themed
birthday party.
My mom made me a
Fanny Brice costume.
-So, you're 3 years old.
That's so shocking to me.
Like, how did you know it?
Were your parents
just playing, like,
the Broadway recording, like --
-My mom showed me the movie.
She was like, "Look at this
iconic Jewish woman
on the screen.
You have to see this at
2 years old."
And I became obsessed with it
and I would ask her to play it.
Like, other kids would be like,
"Play 'The Little Mermaid.'"
I'd be like, "Can we do
'Don't Rain On My Parade'
one more time, please, Mom,
from the top?"
And I just became
obsessed with it.
So, yeah, I'd walk around
my third birthday party, like,
eating all my snacks in my,
you know, Fanny Brice costume.
And all the parents
are laughing,
and all the kids are like,
"What the heck is going on?"
-"What's going on?"
What about --
So, then, it must have been
a pretty special moment
when you told your mom
you were going to do
this on Broadway.
What was that like?
-So, I didn't tell my mom
that I was auditioning,
'cause I was like,
"If this doesn't go my way,
it's going to hurt her
so much more
than it's going to hurt me."
So she had no idea
any of this was happening.
So, when I got the call
that I was going to be
Fanny Brice on Broadway, which
is insane, I called my mom.
And it was during the pandemic.
It was -- Obviously,
we're still in a pandemic,
but it was pre-vaccine.
And I called her and I was like,
"I'm going to come by the house.
Please put your mask on.
And bring dad, come outside.
I'm going to be masked.
But I have something
to tell you."
My mom was like,
"What's going on?
What? What is going on?"
Like, screaming.
Like, literally shaking.
And she's like,
"You just have to tell me,
because I can't sit here."
I'm like,
"It's been four seconds.
You need to calm down."
-Now, do you think -- I don't
know your mom.
Do you think she thought she was
about to hear good news
or do you think she was worried
that it was going to be
bad news?
-I mean, it's Jewish mom.
It's, like, gonna go to the bad.
You know, whatever.
She was like,
"Something is happening
that I don't know about."
-That's really what it is.
Good or bad, it's like,
"I don't know!"
-"I'm not in the know."
And I was like, "I'm going to be
Fanny Brice on Broadway."
And I've never seen her
that happy.
It was honestly, like --
And even my dad --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, thank you.
Even my dad, who's, like --
I think my dad says like
10 words a year.
Like, he literally
doesn't speak.
Was like,
"Bean, that is incredible."
And I was like -- So even he was
excited in his own way, yeah.
-I say -- This is a comment
not on your mother,
but on my mother and things that
she has done in the past.
How quickly after
you gave her the good news
did she start asking for
tickets for her friends?
-It was,
"Can I tell my friends?"
And I was like, "No.
And you can't tell them
for months."
And she was like, "That's going
to be hard for me."
That's going to be tough for me,
because I really wanted to
call -- and if I can't call --"
I'm like, "Okay, relax."
But, yes, the tickets -- she
calls me once a day about them.
I'm like, "I promise
you're going to get to go.
Like, it's not a problem,
I swear."
-"I'm sorry, Mom. It's sold out.
I'm sorry."
We talked about this,
when you were in "Hello, Dolly!"
Your brother, Jonah Hill,
got a "Hello, Beanie" tattoo,
which is just such an incredibly
loving and supporting thing.
-Insane. When he told me he was
going to do it, I was like,
"Get it on your arm," and I
expected it to be like that big.
And it's, like,
truly most of his --
-It's a real big one, yeah.
-Yeah, it's too big, honestly.
-And do we think there's
a "Funny Girl" tattoo
in his future?
I feel like --
-You have to keep up --
If you start this rolling --
-You got to keep up
with the revivals, yeah.
-Yeah, exactly.
If you're not going to put
the revivals on your skin,
where are you --
What are you gonna --
So, yeah, I guess there has to
be some sort of, like --
-I mean, it does seem, like,
very complimentary.
-It's very sweet.
-I mean, he said the
"Hello, Beanie,"
so does he do like,
"Funny Beanie"
or does he do "Beanie Girl?"
-"Beanie Girl"?
Like, what is it?
I don't know.
I'm not that funny, so,
you know, it has to be --
-This must also
be nice to, like,
go into something as joyous
as this after --
While it's an
incredible performance,
"Impeachment"
must have been exhausting,
both the schedule
and just the emotional weight
of what you're playing.
-Yeah, I mean, I was standing
backstage when you were
playing the clip
and I'm like --
You know, it's just --
It's so --
It was really something like
I had never done before.
Most of what I've been
lucky enough to be a part of
in the past
has been leaning comedic,
you know, like a dramedy or like
a true comedy or a musical.
And "Impeachment"
is not only a drama,
but it's someone's real life.
And Monica was a producer
on the show.
So it was a tremendous amount of
responsibility for me.
I really felt like
I wanted to do right by her
in every way
that I possibly could.
And so to do that,
I had to really send myself
into some really intense places.
And Ryan Murphy directed
the episode
from the clip you just saw.
And he'd come up to me and
he would be like,
"How you doing?
Can we go again?"
And I just would be like,
"It's for Monica.
We have to go again.
If you need to go again,
I have to do right by her."
That's, like, all I --
I brush my teeth
thinking about it.
I go to sleep thinking about it.
Like, I do --
Everything in my life
revolves around
doing right by her.
So I -- You know, it's --
What she had to
go through was
really disturbing and intense.
So, yeah, it was very different.
-It's been very nice to sort of
correct the record,
because I think a lot of people,
especially, you know,
younger people,
not that, you know,
older people shouldn't be
excused either,
but I think younger people might
not know the full story
and might know it from,
like, small pieces of, like,
you know, jokes or this or that.
And to actually see
what happened --
I would imagine,
when you would talk to Monica,
who, as you mentioned,
was a producer on it --
Like, what sort of questions
would you ask her
without having to make her
sort of relive it herself?
-Totally. So, she's the producer
and the subject,
so that's, like, a really
tricky thing to navigate.
And, as you said,
I didn't want to make her
sort of rehash the most
traumatic days of her life.
So, by the time I met her,
I'd been researching her
for 10 months, which is, like,
a really weird interaction
of like, "Hello, I know almost
everything about you."
And, so, I really wanted know
things that I just
couldn't find in any
book or any transcript,
because Monica was
interviewed 22 times
by the Office of Independent
Counsel about what happened.
So, unfortunately, there's just
so much material
of her being questioned.
So I wanted things that, like,
you'll just never
be able to find.
Like, her best friend's name
is Catherine.
I was like, "Is she Cat?
Is she Cathy?
Like, when the two of you
are just, like,
alone and hanging,
like, who is she to you?"
You know, these things that I
just couldn't get from any book.
Like, is that Grandma Bubby or
is that Grandma Bubby?
You know, just, like,
these little specificities
that I couldn't find.
And she was so gracious and she
was so giving to all of us
from every stage of the project,
and I just --
Yeah, I hope we
did right by her.
-I think you did.
Congratulations on that.
I'm so excited for "Funny Girl."
And thanks so much
for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
I'm so happy.
-It's always a delight.
Beanie Feldstein, everybody.
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story,"
airs Tuesdays on FX.